el 11 de marzo de 2022 el presidente
Gabriel borich asumió el poder en Chile
abriendo una etapa inédita la de un
mandato de cuatro años otorgado al jefe
de estado más joven de la historia del
país
Un año más tarde el balance de su
gestión se demarcado por la baja
popularidad y una serie de tropiezos en
la semana previa la celebración del
primer año de gobierno el mandatario
sufrió un revés la cámara de diputados
rechazó su proyecto de reforma fiscal
pieza central del programa de su
gobierno preveía Un aumento progresivo
de los impuestos para los sectores más
ricos del país con el fin de financiar
nuevos derechos sociales en educación
pensiones y salud esta fue la segunda
derrota del ejecutivo chileno la primera
ocurrió el 4 de septiembre de 2022
cuando el 62% de los votantes rechazó el
proyecto de una nueva constitución el
golpe que le significó al plebiscito del
4 de septiembre sin duda tan valió
muchísimo al gobierno ha sido un
terremoto que le ha afectado tanto desde
el punto de vista de su proyecto
político que quería instalar en Chile
pero también respecto de quiénes eran
las autoridades quienes eran los voceros
que Ellos tenían al interior del
gobierno otra crisis para el gobierno
fue la del conflicto mapuche en el sur
del país donde la población indígena
reclama desde hace años la devolución de
las tierras ancestrales si bien el
presidente había criticado la
militarización de la zona por parte del
gobierno anterior dio un giro de 180
grados al anunciar el regreso de los
militares pero a pesar de todos estos
contratiempos el primer aniversario de
su mandato coincide también con signos
de recuperación económica con una caída
de la inflación el control del desempleo
y un fortalecimiento del peso frente a
las Divisas extra